want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack
of belief in yourself you watch these
videos because you know there's
something more
inside you too you've got michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from robin sharma
enjoy
the very nature of being a human being
is we are built to progress we know that
the human brain craves novelty
and we are most alive we have the most
energy we are most intimate with our
best selves
when we're progressing towards our
mighty mission so i think we all want
i think what's happened on the planet
right now is there's been a great
seduction and a great brainwashing
when we are kids we want we want to be
astronauts
we want to be billionaires we want to be
history makers
we want to do all our dreams and then
and
we stand in awe and wonder and we're
full of curiosity and we're loving
and we're passionate we're strong we're
not afraid to be ourselves
but as we leave the perfection of
childhood the hypnosis and the
brainwashing begins our well-intentioned
parents say
oh you want to be an astronaut you want
to start a business
when you grow up you want to paint like
joe michelle basquiat
be reasonable and
george bernard shaw said it better than
i ever could he said the reasonable man
adapts himself to the world the
unreasonable one persists in adapting
the world to himself
therefore all progress depends on the
unreasonable man
so that's our nature but our parents
give us limitation based on their
limited psychology and their emotional
patterns that they learn from their
parents
then we go to school and we're taught to
live in a box think in a box
dress like everyone else don't sing too
loudly don't dream too big don't be too
passionate
and then our peers do the same thing to
us and then society says
oh genius is the realm of genetics not
everyday people which has been
dismissed by some very good science you
know i mean the ten thousand hour rule
that we all know
from a florida state university
professor anders erickson
it just confirmed so much so i do think
we all want
i think what's happened is we've as
we've left who we truly are
we've contracted and now it's all about
staying safe in the world versus going
out there and
letting our brilliance our primal genius
shine
and a lot of people just have stuff that
pain of disappointment
and their doubt really deep inside and
they just are addicted to distraction
and escapes because they don't want to
deal with their
potential that they've denied and i
think that's that's an important point
which is i think we live in a world
where
the the seduction is to push
a thousand pieces of mediocrity versus
deliver
one piece of mastery and what i mean by
that is
if you spend 20 years on one book but it
is the greatest
book that you could possibly do then
that's a win
and by the way even if the world doesn't
applaud what you bring to the world
if you've delivered your piece of magic
to the world your sistine
chapel ceiling to the world you've won
yes
you know we live in this world that is
much more about egoism versus heroism
and i think heroism is
it's it's really the race is really a
race against yourself i'm not
that into applause and and you know
worldly accolades i think if you feel
you've done your best and you've been
true to your creativity and you've lived
by your values
and you've released what you believe to
be magic to the world and you've done
your best to raise others while you've
honored yourself you're a hero you've
won
you know it doesn't matter if if you're
an army of one i mean van gogh didn't
i believe then go didn't sell one piece
of art while he was alive
your phone is costing you your fortune
it is an addiction it's a dopamine
addiction
break start the process of breaking your
addiction
to distraction here in this room today
you've invested in this you're a
learning investor the best
investment you can make is being in this
room
why would you spend it checking your
notifications looking at your email
looking at sms looking at
pictures of people's breakfasts or like
why would you do that
this is your life this is your career
this is your craft
this is your service to humanity
why would you why would you be checking
[Music]
your phone and if you look at a victim
if you look look at most people on the
planet
they're literally hooked to a white
screen they are wasting
their human potential hooked into some
social platform
that is creating empires for other
people
many people if not most people are now a
form of artificial intelligence
they're not living their brains
potential they're not living their
physiological potential
they're not living their creative
potential they're not living their human
potential
they're not living their economic
potential why because they're hooked to
a screen
it is the most frightening time in the
history of the world and it's the most
gorgeous time in the history of humanity
why
because it's never been so easy to be a
hero
because most people aren't doing it most
people are lost most people are hooked
so turn off your phones get
serious about this this is your game
this is your life
this is your sport and before you know
it you will be at the end we all know
that life goes by
in a bling also if you want to have more
self belief and more self confidence
i've created a special
free program where every day for the
next 254 days i will send you
an unlisted video to help you boost your
self-belief and self-confidence the link
to join for free
is in the description below and so stop
resisting i encourage you stop resisting
the natural flow of epic performance
stop resisting the natural
seasons of life i've gone through
situations where
yeah people have tried to take me down
you're absolutely right i've had
10 years of my personal journals where i
pour my heart my confusion my pain my
hopes my dream
i've had those um i'll just simply say
taken
wow which taught me detachment wow
louis imagine do you journal um a little
bit here there yes
a little bit okay journaling is like
incredibly powerful yeah
for self-excavation for creativity
productivity
we can get into epigenetics you know if
you want to rewire
your psychology as well as your heart
journaling is powerful but i've had
those taken taken away from you
just taken away from 10 years of
journals oh 10 years of journals
oh my god all your private thoughts all
my private
exactly so that's just one thing that
i've gone through
um so what was the lesson there learning
detachment and letting go
not caring about the opinions of others
yeah yeah there's been another time of
my life and i don't think i've ever
shared this publicly but
where there was a situation where i
could have lost everything that i've
spent 22 years
in this field of leadership and personal
personal mastery building
which again taught me
what real wealth and success is all
about i mean there's a line in the 5am
club which is your piece of
nothing is worth the price of your peace
of mind
tranquility is the new luxury
so whether you're a homemaker a
professional athlete
an entrepreneur a pizza builder maybe
that's not the term of art
but you do your best work we have our
greatest
impact and we are most true to our best
selves
when we're tranquil peaceful
and serene and that's another value of
joining the 5 am club
because those hours before the sun rises
are the most
peaceful magical quiet period of the day
and if we can
anchor in who we truly want to be before
we go out into a messy world
well we're going to fundamentally behave
differently clarity
is the dna of mastery so if you look at
the titans of business
the true leaders in finance these people
literally will say
look at my charts they if you look at a
great military leader you look at a
great athlete
they have such granular in a world of
superficiality
they have shifted to massive granularity
so they know in intimate detail exactly
what their future timeline will look
like
why because clarity breeds and
builds and is the dna of mastery
you want to have a very clear
vision of what your future is going to
look like
and when you know in intimate detail
what your future will look like
then you automatically subconsciously as
well as consciously
can say no to the important so you say a
giant
yes to the few things that are most
important you've heard me share this
before confucius said it so well
per the person who chases two rabbits
catches
neither and so what i'm encouraging you
to do is this exercise before you go to
sleep tonight let's make this very
tactical
i call it the 100 year timeline on a
single page
a single page from where you now are 100
years out into your ideal
future i want you every single milestone
on a single line
to say here's where i now am here's
what's going to happen
next week next month next quarter
next year three years five years 10
years
25 years 50 years 75 years
one year 100 years until you have a 100
year timeline on the other side of the
piece of paper
with crayons so you tap into
your part of the brain responsible for
creativity
your right brain okay with crayons draw
out your ideal family life
draw up one year away draw out your
business life one year away draw out
your adventure life
one year out into the future draw out
your financial life draw out your
material life
literally on a page with crayons so
you're not thinking because
here's a i think a needle-moving insight
world-class comes from instinct versus
intelligence
you get your best ideas when you get out
of your thinking and just to give you
some
neuroscience the seat of reasoning is
the prefrontal cortex but there's a
phenomenon i teach in my live events
called
transient hypo frontality this is the
secret of genius
geniuses don't get their ideas for uber
amazon
the electric bulb tesla
shakespeare the polio vaccination
spacex great ideas don't come from the
intellect the
they don't come from the neocortex
reasoning and thinking
all great heroes and great inventors and
great creators
dialed into something deeper when you
get out of your neocortex
through solitude and my life structure
that i teach called the tight bubble of
total focus
and when you get away from distraction
and you immerse yourself
in deep creativity and creation and you
find
your laboratory or what i call your
menlo park like edison it is menlo park
which was with the wilderness away from
the world what happens the prefrontal
cortex
gets silent and it's called transient
transient which means temporary
transient hypo small frontality
the neocortex the seat in your brain of
thinking
actually shuts down for a short period
of time this is
profound information and will confirm
your brain is built for genius
but if you don't do the right things
you're not going to be able to allow the
genius
to see the light of day you might have a
great mindset positive thinking
but if you have a heart set full of
anger if your emotional life
is sad if you're disappointed from the
past
if you haven't done that the sweat
lodges and the journaling and the body
work and the affirmations
to really open up a heart set then you
can have
the mindset of elon musk you have the
mindset of a steve jobs you can have a
mindset of a kobe
but you're going to sabotage yourself
from world class and
to me this is the great myth of positive
thinking you see a lot of people
they read all the books they're positive
thinkers they've got the vision boards
nothing changes why because
subconsciously
there's this wounding and a lack of
deservability
and it's unconscious and so they haven't
done the work or you may have not done
the work to make the
wounds of underservability and scarcity
and the low self-worth that's why
positive thinking alone
does not work this is to me a
revolutionary insight and by the way
a lot of the people who teach positive
thinking in the past
are men so it's very male mind
and a lot of the people who are pioneers
of heartset
are women heart empathy
healing and so self-mastery to me
and this is a pioneering model that i
teach at personal mastery academy
it's not just mindset that's only 25 of
self mastery and as you know
self mastery is the dna of outer mastery
you're never going to perform higher
than what's going on within
mindset is only 25 heart set
your emotional life working from
confidence
and love and service
and that sense of internal freedom is
only another 25
so those two are only 50 there's a third
interior empire you want to get to world
class which is
health set working on your energy your
nutrition
your daily exercise hacking your
longevity eating the right supplements
getting a massage every two weeks you
know my two massage protocol
doing your 60 minute nature walk every
week so that your
health set is at world class but that's
only 75 percent of the equation towards
self mastery you have a great mindset
great heart set great health set but if
you haven't worked on your soul set
turning down your ego you know you know
what disease and
what energy depletion is caused by your
ego
beating you relentlessly about you not
being enough
and seeing your industry peers
succeeding and you feel
insecure and irritated and angry and
jealous
well where do you do that work within
your soul set
the fourth interior empire
and as you do that you turn down the ego
and you open up your humanity and you
open up your spiritual life
and you become more soulful and then you
release work that is
artistry versus just to win in the next
few months
when you literally give your life over
to a mighty mission that is larger than
your ego
and you literally start to see your work
as a ministry for the benefit of
humanity
and if you literally if you're an artist
or an entrepreneur or ceo manager or
coder
a doctor or fighter firefighter but
literally
if you saw your work as your poetry and
your artistry
and you were on a mighty mission that
was larger than even your
your ego and yourself
what would the caliber of your output be
so few people who could succeed actually
do succeed
because they've given up on learning
study
and growth lsg learning
study and growth so
the neurobiologists and
neuropsychologists will tell us that the
human brain
craves learning and it craves curiosity
and it craves novelty and unfortunately
a lot of us
we learned in school but the moment we
left school
and walked out into the world we've
given up on
our personal commitment to growth and so
i'm inviting you
with great love and respect to reclaim
the curiosity you once knew as a child
when you were overflowing with awe and
wonder
you see our natural state is the way we
are we're as children
we're built to be curious we're built to
be passionate we're built to be
full of energy we're built to question
things you look at a little child and
it's like
mommy daddy why why why why you look at
an
adult and they've contracted their
curiosity
they've given up on seeing the magic in
the world they no longer
grow and so the mindset i want you to
start practicing
because no idea works unless you do the
work
to install a core belief you just
practice it
until it becomes automatic that's how
you actually get
to change your psychology and so the
mindset i invite you to start practicing
each day
is what i call the 2x 3x mindset
to double your income and your
impact triple your investment in two
core areas
number one your personal mastery and
number two
your professional capability and how do
you do that again you do it through
learning study and growth
so i guess what i'm suggesting to you is
you look at most of the population
and you commit yourself to what i call
anti-majority behavior
if you want to have a great life a
soaring life a creative life a
productive life a
ultra prosperous life look at what most
people do
and do the opposite so most people
what they do is they love consuming as
opposed to creating
we live in a civilization of consumers
buy this eat this do this
consume this but the top five percent
those who play in the rare era of world
class are not consumers
they're creators suffering gets a bad
rap in our world today in society we all
want to quit but if you look at
again nelson mandela mother teresa
mothma gandhi a rosa parks
a martin luther king jr um
a marcus aurelius you look at the great
states people the great
women who led who led nations the great
men who led movements you i've been
studying samurai
samurai lately you know i've been
studying a lot of the great warriors
i've been reading a lot about
alexander the great you could say well
robin you know in in the comment section
or whatever you could say robin
some of these people were were bloody
you know some of these warriors and i
hear you my larger point is simply this
if you look at the great warriors
or the great empire builders or the
great
heroes of humanity they all had one
thing in common
many of them developed invincible
moral authority to live by their deepest
vision values and virtues
through the hard winters
of deep suffering a gca a gargantuan
competitive advantage
in a world where everyone everyone wants
it easy they want a
a warm house they want to they want
a car with heated seats if you live in a
cold place
we want great food we want a life of
ease we want
all our devices around us we want easy
friends who don't make us
maybe who don't stretch us we want to if
we even read
we want easy books we
i guess what i'm suggesting to you is
voluntary
discomfort will build you and strengthen
you
and the great heroes of history often
didn't do it voluntarily
they suffered they suffered in a prison
cell they suffered for the benefit of
their movement
they suffered long treks through
mountains with not a lot of food
when they're on a military campaign they
suffered
the humiliation of being attacked by
their critics
and so in this age of ease
we are becoming weak as leaders weak as
humans
weak as possibilitarians and i'm just
saying to you
sure heavier nice things you know we all
want a nice life myself included
and yet make sure you don't fall into
the chasm or
the the trap of
living a life that is so easy that you
don't develop
those muscles of strength
fiery resolve and moral authority why do
so many people on the planet right now
medicate themselves they medicate
themselves with too much technology
anyone agree with me show off hands or a
round of applause like
they are they are medicating themselves
in front of that white screen 110 times
checking the smartphone every day
that is not checking your technology you
know what that is
that is an addiction
[Music]
and an escape from what is
and if you said to most people did you
know you're addicted to your smartphone
did you know you're addicted to your
notifications did you know you're
addicted to your television did you know
you're addicted to your excuses did you
know you're addicted to gossip did you
know you're drinking too much alcohol
because you are addicted to it did you
know that this is all a flight
from what is because deep down inside
the deepest unknown part of you knows
that you are in pain
over potential unlived
they would fight you to the death am i
making sense here show of hands
deep down aside i believe most people on
the planet
are heartbroken why because they have
betrayed
the visions ambitions values mission
in their heart they have betrayed their
talent
by buying into the mass hypnosis that
the world
has sold them and now they're 35 and
they're 45 years old
and they're just oh no no this is what
everyone does and they just check check
check and then
you know what blaze pascal the french
mathematician said most
people their misery their misery is
derived
by their inability to sit quietly
in a room by themselves
you know how many people you know how
many people are
frightened of their own company
and i've shared with you right now
seriously they're frightened of their
own company
i've shared with you the neurobiology
transient hypofrontality you can't play
at
edison you can't play at misty copeland
you can't play it world class unless you
bring yourself away from the world and
do the practice
do the training do the thinking to set
up transient
to set up transient hypo frontality
and that creates the pharmacy of mastery
and it brings you from beta to alpha
and it releases the dopamine and the
serotonin
and the psychologists have told us that
state
is flow and i guess what i've been
suggesting with transient hypofrontality
you have flow within you you have genius
within you most of us
are so distracted they're so over
stimulated
they're so interrupted that they don't
create the silent spaces where their
genius can present themselves secondly
most people the 95 percent
this is no judgment just reporting but
they're pleasure seekers
if you look at the true warriors of
humanity you look at the true empire
builders you look at the true
titans who are constructing a better
world they're less about pleasure
seeking because they understand
that growth comes through discomfort
willpower is built through voluntary
acts
of quote-unquote suffering i mean
to do hard work is to grow to push
yourself on a project to places that
frighten you
is to expand your creative capabilities
i hope i'm making sense for you here
but pleasure seekers don't create
monuments if you look at the taj mahal
if you look at
piazza navona in rome if you look at the
great wall of china if you look at
the mona lisa created by davinci if you
look at the sistine
chapel created mike michelangelo if you
look at any
any great company okay an apple under
steve jobs for example or it might have
been
uh elon musk's companies i don't know
what companies most speak to you but if
you look at any world-class company
under armour comes to mind
these companies took grit they took
suffering they took relentless
relentlessness
any creative person has to face the
arrows and slings of their critics so
you get to world class
through the doorway of discomfort and
how do you build a strong inner core
you do it by walking into the
metaphorical hard
winters of growth that's how you train
you look at a great athlete it's the way
they show up in the championship
game is simply how they
showed up in the lonely light of the
early
hours at practice it wasn't easy i mean
i always think of muhammad ali he said
i didn't like any one of those early
morning training sessions
but i said to myself suffer now and
spend the rest of your life
as a champion we live in a world where
the dominant
message of society is if you want to be
a leader
be be sort of mean be aggressive
you know you got to thump your chest a
little more if you want to lead the
field
you got to speak a little bit louder
you've got to
be all about me versus thinking about we
and so what i want to offer to you right
now is simply
a reminder because your
wisest part knows the truth you know on
the last hour of your last day
when you reflect on your life if you
were not kind
i think you're going to feel heartbroken
one of my mentors when i was a young
lawyer was a judge
and a very special man i learned so much
from him i was so incredibly influenced
by his commitment to excellence by his
integrity
and by his outright honor and a few
years ago
he had retired and i made the trek back
to
where he was living and we spent two
glorious hours together
where we remembered you know our best
times when i was working for him
and towards the end of our conversation
i asked him for advice you know like
what's most important what are the best
lessons you've learned from life
what suggestions do you have for me as i
go forward
as i pursue my mountaintops and he said
this and he said
you know he spoke of excellence and he
spoke of honesty and then at the very
end of our conversation he said
and robin please always remember
to be kind he said oh robin
it's so important to be kind
and then he reached over and he did
something he'd never done
he hugged me and he said robin
i love you leadership is not about a
title leadership
is not about the size of your office
leadership is not about having
formal authority leadership is a mindset
leadership is a way of operating through
your days leadership is a heart set
leadership is a way of being and i think
you know we're now in leadership 2.0
the old model of leadership said you
need to have a lot of money or you need
to
be a prime minister or president you
need to be a ceo or a managing director
in order to be a leader leadership 2.0
is fundamentally different
leadership 2.0 simply says if you
can breathe if you are alive you not
only have the opportunity
you have the responsibility to show
leadership not only in your work
not only in your creativity not only in
your impact not only in your influence
but even in your personal life install
the lead without a title
mindset and again that's just a way of
thinking it's an approach
no matter what you do no matter what
your station in life is
start thinking like a leader because you
really have a choice when you go in the
world every day you can be a victim
or you can be a leader but you can't do
both and so the more you practice
showing leadership in your work showing
leadership with your family showing
leadership in your community showing
leadership in your private self
practice drives performance and the more
you practice it the more you start to
step into the mindset of a leader
without a title
i mean the reality is reading a book or
going to a conference or having a great
conversation
where you get this golden information
that's all fantastic
but what makes mastery is execution on
the ideas
not the ideas and so no idea works
unless you're willing to roll up your
sleeves
do the practice invest the time put in
the effort
do the work i think we've all observed a
lot of people
who they love reading the books they
love showing up at the courses they
do all the online training and nothing
ever changes
and they say well you know i don't know
why it doesn't change why my life
doesn't change
why my thinking doesn't change why my
performance doesn't change
why my relationships don't change well
it's because
ideas don't work if you don't execute on
them
so if you look at the great business
builders you look at any great performer
one thing that makes them great is their
grit
one thing that makes them great is their
hunger
to practice one thing that makes them
great
is they are willing to sacrifice i mean
yes they're passionate but did you know
the root of the word passion
is suffering you've got to be willing to
suffer
for your vision you've got to be willing
to suffer
to reach biw best in world you've got to
be willing to suffer
the ridicule and laughter of your
critics and your cynics to get to a
place
called world class nothing fails like
success
you're successful maybe it's in your
health maybe it's in your finances maybe
it's in your career
maybe it's in your family life maybe
it's in the way that you show up in the
world
awesome you're in a really vulnerable
place right now
it is one thing to be successful it is
another thing to sustain
success over the coming decades is that
not a powerful idea
i mean let's go to the entertainment
industry
it's very hard to be a one-hit wonder
let's not knock a one-hit wonder
but it's even harder to become an iconic
rock band or hip-hop band
let's go to the arts it is very
hard to come up with your sistine chapel
got it
it is even harder to become a
michelangelo
so are you playing the short game or are
you playing the long game this is rule
number
two you know or lesson number two that
life has taught me
play the long game aim for legendary
don't just say i want to be world class
in my dominant pursuit for a little
window of time say
i wanna have the guts and the grit and
the acumen
and the mindset and the capability and
the commitment
to create enduring success and that's
why i say nothing fails like success
you look at the restaurant that is hot
in your neighborhood right now
they're on the path to obsolescence if
they're not really careful
sure they went from a little
neighborhood shop
that made beautiful pasta that had great
servers
that had the owner on the floor shaking
your hand
getting to know your name then they got
written up in the magazines and they
then they got
interviewed and then word of mouth
spread like wildfire
and what happened they became arrogant
you see success can be so
toxic and it happens it is such a pull
on every human being it just plays with
your mind
and you literally shift from humility to
arrogance
you shift from humility to arrogance and
once the arrogance sets in in a mindset
it starts to populate every other person
on the team every other person in the
culture
every other person in the community and
it is a very short fall
from success to irrelevance
so lesson number two is nothing fails
like success as you become more
successful
become more humble as you become more
successful work even harder
as you become more successful care even
more about your product
as you become more successful learn even
more
i invite you it when you are the the
titan of your
industry be sitting in the room with
18 year olds beginning their game
when you are the the the icon of your
field be the person who is up not at
five o'clock anymore let's play at four
o'clock
reading listening to the podcast writing
in your journal
setting your goals focusing on your
intentions
as you become more successful be more
humble as you become more successful
be even more punctual as you become more
successful
become even more passionate as you
become older become
even younger yesterday i was walking on
the street
and i met this man in his 80s he said
robin i finally retired he's probably
close to 90.
and he is um a legendary
clothier in the country that i live in
and he just retired
and he started his shop which is now an
empire in 1954. so i don't know what
that is but that is decades and decades
and decades and decades decades
and he did not want to retire he just
retired but he is still
on fire to do amazing things age is just
a number do not let an old person into
your body
nothing fails like success i think
failure is the highway to success and i
know that sounds like a platitude but
society
or people teach us right they say oh if
you fail and feel uncomfortable you've
done something wrong and
what i try to do in all of my books and
my presentations and my tweets and
is the you cannot
get to the mountaintop without taking a
few missteps
and so a business that wants to win you
have to out fail your competition
and as human beings you know failure is
not a bad thing
you know ask yourself what's the
opportunity from the failure and get in
the game because when you get to the
last hour of your last day
it will not be the failures you regret
it'll be all the risks you didn't take
we become our standards in many ways if
you are
surrounded by b players or average
performers
and that is your standard then your
mindset will
operate at the standard that is
that is offered to you by the people
around you i mean we do become our
social orbit
and if you are at a standard internally
that i want to be a game changer in my
field i want to be biw the best there
ever was i want to be the
van gogh and the rembrandt of technology
or whatever field you play in
then your behavior always matches your
internal identity
and your inner standards so your
standards are important your standards
for your friendships
your standards for the quality of the
work you do the standards of your
languaging the standards of the
nutrition you put into your body
the standards of your love life the
standards of
your mindset the standards of the way
you occur
in the world and so my invitation for
you
regardless of what you do is that you
raise your game
to a place called world class and that
is all about being a game changer
now i should caution you and i don't
like that word because
language is so powerful and caution is a
word that really is a little dramatic
but i want to caution you which is as
you leave
the herd and the crowd and perhaps the
cult of mediocrity and rise to
being a game changer it's a very
disruptive act
and you actually threaten the masses of
people around you
and that's why every visionary was first
ridiculed before they were revered and
i'm sure you've experienced it you want
to set you say
you know i want to take my fitness to a
whole new level of world class or i want
to take my craft to a whole new level of
world class or
maybe you're raising your game
financially
and then you share with those you love
or your friend your friends and
maybe your friends are those you love
and they laugh at you
and how many times have we given up on a
dream because we were mocked by the
people around you and all i'm suggesting
to you is when you get laughed at and
ridiculed
and when people don't understand your
next level of world class
that just means you've got a great dream
and that just means you're on the path
of growth
so be a game changer small wins matter
i mean we sometimes think that a an epic
life occurs one
sunday sunday friday afternoon when the
stars line up
and something revolutionary occurs and
what i'm suggesting to you with great
love and great respect is
a great life is built not by revolution
a great life is built by evolution
small and steady wins the race
what you do every day is far more
important than what you what you do
once every decade i want you to really
think about that idea what you do
every day is simply your life in
miniature
and as you live every single day so
you're crafting your life
what you do over the next hours is
really building your future
and if you can just get and i can just
get every single
pocket of 24 hours
right as best as we humanly can the rest
of our life is going to take care of
itself so
small wins matter you know the
moment in front of the customer where
the pull
was to go average and you become
merchant of wow
sets you up for the next day of a way of
being of wow
the little win with your family when you
feel like watching tv
sets you up for another win the next day
a little win of getting up at five
o'clock and running your morning routine
sets you up for a habit of a 5 a.m club
morning routine small daily improvements
over time will lead you
to stunning results tiny wins are the
way
to greatness and that's one of the
things life has taught me when you look
at the great companies whether it's an
amazon whether it's you know some of the
some of the
tech startups coming out right now
whether it's a zappos whether it's a
fedex whether it's a nike
whether it's a general electric whether
it's some of the you know the the little
shops in your neighborhood that we
really admire
because people still cook the food with
love or they serve the food with love or
people have an attention to detail great
companies are built
by those small steady optimizations
every single day if you look at any
great product it wasn't just
one day that built a great product it
was a culture and a mindset
of daily innovation and optimization
when done consistently over time
which led to world class even even
relationships
a great relationship it's all about
those small daily wins when done
consistently leads to a lifetime of love
i was walking in the woods last week and
there were these
there was an elderly couple walking in
front of me and they really stood out
because they were moving fast
uh and i and they were also like they
had these ski poles
and so this i mean this is the autumn
in my hometown and they were walking
with these ski poles and so i sort of
joked as i walked by them because it
pretty much
only the three of us in this deep forest
and i said you're missing the snow
and they sort of laughed and we actually
walked for about half an hour
and we started going pretty deep and
they said to me you know
we've been married 52 years
and i said 52 years what's your secret
and the woman says
well we've i've had to put up with a lot
which made me laugh
and then it was all about the little
small daily things they did
to foster a lifetime of love i believe
that
potential unexpressed turns to pain
and
when we are born we're born as children
into awe
and wonder adults are nothing more than
deteriorated children
but as we leave the perfection of
childhood where we're intimate
with our gifts and our talents and on
wonder
our parents doing their best say you
want to be an astronaut be
practical then we go to school we say i
want to be a rock star and i want to be
an actor and
i want to be jay shetty when i grow up
and they say oh no no he's a different
kind of
cut from a different cloth than you and
we
we we get seduced by the beliefs of the
people around
us and we go from this on wonder and
intimacy with our glory our primal glory
that's
that's just the human condition and we
start to forget who we truly are
and as our dreams start to fall apart
and as we lose that connection with our
best selves and as we get sad and
disappointed
and as we failed that's just part of
life a lot of us shut down
and we don't know how to process through
that pain so we we repress
it and so the great sports superstars or
the billionaires i work with or
the you know companies like starbucks
fedex nike ibm when i work with their
leadership teams
what i do is i help them move through
that well
of blockage within themselves because
in the book there's a very disruptive
model
and it's called the four interior
empires and just really quickly so many
people are talking about mindset would
you agree
absolutely everything is mindset if you
just
dial in your mindset you're going to go
out there and you're going to change the
world well here's
here's what that model is about i i
think mindset is only 25
of the personal mastery equation yeah
and here's why
it's very important to have a great
mindset that's your psychology you want
to wire in the beliefs of world class no
question but a great psychology
with a broken heart or a heart full of
pain if you haven't forgiven
the unforgiven if you're stuck in the
past
you can read the books and go to the
courses and get a great mindset you're
all on fire
but you sabotage yourself because your
emotional life is toxic
so it's not just mindset there's a
second word i'm introducing which is
it's going to transform people it's
heart set
but it's not only purifying your heart
set you want to
calibrate your mindset purify your heart
set
and then it's this other word i'm
introducing health set that's the third
interior empire
because if you want to change the world
don't die
right you know yes so one of the keys to
legendary is longevity
and there's a lot of the book on how to
how the best in the world the great
geniuses manage their vitality so they
were like in their 90s still
rocking their craft so it's mindset
heartset health set
which is your physical life and here's a
key that i think will resonate with you
it's
the fourth interior empire is your soul
set yes now
some of your listeners from across the
planet will go well i'm a business
builder or i want
creativity productivity why are we
talking about soul so well
if your ego is running the day you're
never going to go out there and change
the world
you know a bad day for the ego is an
awesome day for the soul
so working on your soul sets so you are
a titan of humanity and you're
intimate with your highest nature and
you're wiring in the great
values and you're living for a cause
that's bigger than yourself
that's what allows you to go out in the
world and move through failures
and really own your domain so those four
interior empires
once you work on those you go out in the
world
and automatically everything you touch
is golden
because our outer success is always a
function of who we
are before the sun rises is the time of
fleece distraction
before the sun rises where you can build
intimacy and fluency with what you want
to stand for
in your day before the sun rises the
luxury and tranquility of the early
morning hours you can do that deep inner
work
that will allow you to go out in the
world and and play at your best so what
the 20 20 20 formula is is simply this
there's
three pockets the first pocket is move
five to five twenty and you get into the
sweaty exercise because like i mentioned
it
releases uh neurotransmitters it
reduces the cortisol increases your
metabolic rate which gives you more
energy
so now and serotonin as well which gives
you joy
so now it's 5 20. fundamentally you feel
different you have energy your state is
strong you've got a fire in your belly
and you've accelerated your focus
520 to 540 is the second pocket
of the 20 20 20 formula which is reflect
we live in a world where a lot of people
are busy being busy but what's the point
of being
busy around climbing the wrong mount
everests
and so clarity is one of the dnas of
mastery
you know this if you talk to the titans
of industry and you talk to the people
really getting traction around their
ambition
these are people who have a monomaniacal
focus on the few things that matter
they have an obsession bordering on a
possession around the few priorities
they want to build their life around and
so 520
to 540 the second pocket you write in a
journal
you meditate you visualize
you do what i call in the book a
blueprint for a beautiful day
or you just sit in solitude and you
think and you ponder and you reflect
and then the final pocket is 5 40 to 6
o'clock and this is the victory hour
the final pocket is grow but if you look
at the greatest billionaires i've
coached
many billionaires over the past 20 years
if you look at the greatest producers on
the planet these people have one thing
in common they are ridiculously curious
and no matter how much money they make
and no matter how much impact they have
they maintain a white belt mentality one
of the keys to
epic performance is a relentless
commitment to
daily growth so that's the 20 20 20
formula that the 5 a.m method is built
around
and the premise is basically this as you
begin your day
so you hand craft the rest of your day
and if you have consistently great days
you're going to have consistently great
weeks
quarters a year and a lifetime so your
days are life and miniature and you got
to get those
mornings calibrated if you really want
to win every genius entrepreneur
has an eccentric vision so they're
possibilitarians
they are the people who said you know
well here's the way the industry has
always been
and here's the way the status quo is but
here's what we're going to do what's
coming to the top of my mind right now
as i record this is uber so you've got
travis kalniak
and literally through that single app i
mean they don't own any taxis they don't
own any cars
they don't really have any inventory but
through that
single app uber disrupted the entire
industry of
that level of transportation and so
you know these people these genius
entrepreneurs
come up with a ridiculously disruptive
idea
that is absolutely eccentric in its
vision
and that's why people call them crazy
and i'll simply say to you
if your vision is not routinely called
crazy then perhaps your vision isn't big
enough
and disruptive enough and we changed the
world when we changed the game
bono is sharing the story that i believe
he heard
and it was the person walks inside kanye
west's living room
surveys the living room and cannot
believe
what's on one wall of kanye west's
living room and it's this giant poster
of kanye west and so the person who's in
the living room goes kanye it's a
beautiful living room but
why do you have this massive poster of
yourself
in your own living room and kanye
replies
well if i don't believe in myself no
one's going to believe in me
and my take on that insight is simply
this
no one's going to believe in your lofty
vision no one is going to embrace
and enroll in your mighty mission
if you don't viscerally believe in it i
mean no one's going to believe in you
unless you believe in you and kanye
you know in many ways is a disrupter in
his field
and kanye in many ways is playing at
mastery in terms of his craft
but that's coming from this incredible
self-belief and yes i understand
some people will say he's arrogant and i
in no way am encouraging anyone to be
arrogant uh or vain but the larger point
for you and
i as people on the rise to mastery and
creating lives that are
legendary is to really dial in on that
insight which is you know what
we really do have to have the confidence
to believe in ourselves because
a lot of time as a leader a lot of time
as a business builder
a lot of time as a craftsperson we will
be
in the wilderness we will have an idea
for a business or a product
where the rest of the world says that's
impossible
and we have to be coming from a place
from within where our
i can is larger than our i can
you absolutely must do the interior work
required
where you have these fiery levels of
confidence
where when the world is saying you know
what i dismiss your vision
or that is impossible you have to be
that
lone voice who goes no you know what
it is possible and just watch me do it
you can be a history maker
or you can be liked by everyone around
you
you can't be both i mean the very nature
of living your personal greatness and
doing something
otherworldly in our world of ours means
you're gonna have to think differently
from the majority you're going to have
to install the habits and routines
that most people don't do you're going
to have to live
talk breathe walk work
produce create in a way that
most people who are card carrying
members of the cult of mediocrity
just don't buy into i mean you look at
most people out on the world
today and this is not judging this is
just reporting
but they're addicted to entertainment
they love gossiping they're negative
they're toxic
anyone who wants to do anything great
they want to bring them down
they dismiss the game changers and
they're just coasting through life
and so the very nature of you stepping
up your game
living your greatest potential owning
your craft
dominating your field and living a life
that's legendary means you're gonna have
to leave the five percent
and make a decision to live as very few
people do
and what does that mean it means you're
going to be laughed at it means you're
going to be ridiculed
it means you're going to be
misunderstood because leadership is a
lonely sport
and it means you just might be hated and
so there is great value when people
start to hate you
because if you look at jay-z i mean i
was reading his biography
and he said you know i really knew that
i was having influence
in the popular culture when people
started hating me
if you look a lot of the great authors
when their books go to number one
globally
a lot of the amateurs actually start to
say oh that's garbage i could put them
down
i watched a documentary last night on
steve aioli the
famous edm electric dance music dj who's
getting so much traction in the world
right now
and he was talking about some of the
comments that he sees in the social
media
and it was things like garbage and you
know boring and
amateurish music and whatever even
though he's so skilled i mean you
just watched the documentary called
i'll i'll sleep when i'm dead
and you just see the skill and you can
just look at any great athlete and you
can look at any great scientist
you can look at any great chef you could
look at any great
artist you can look at any great
author you can look at any great
statesman you can look at any
world-class states woman anyone who has
done something
at an exceptional level breeds
cynics and dismissors so
the point is simply this the very nature
of doing something that very few people
are willing to do
means that the majority will laugh at
you
why because deep inside they know they
have the opportunity
to do something great too and all i'm
suggesting to you with great love and
respect is simply this
you do have a choice you can listen to
your haters
you can be one of the haters you can
join the victim herd
you can dismiss people who are doing
great things or you can reach into
yourself and ask yourself this
fundamental question
what do i want to stand for for the rest
of my life do i really want to rise to
mastery
do i want to get to the last hour of my
last day
and know that i took every ounce of the
human potential i was blessed with
and through easy times and difficult
times
i brought it on and every as a result of
my values
my mindsets my heart set
my habits my routines my disciplines
i was i owned my game and i modeled
possibility
and i served lots of people and i built
a great lifestyle
and now it's the last hour of my last
day and i'm surrounded by
by my loved ones and even though people
threw stones at me i took
those stones and rather than being
knocked down
i constructed a monument
of mastery that stands as my legacy
and if you live like that you'll be one
of the great ones
you're in a restaurant the server
generally gives you what you expect
or less than what you expect you go into
a clothing store
it's what you expect or less than what
you expect
you do business with any organization
it's generally delivering on what you
expect
but more often even less so you have a
gorgeous opportunity to lead the field
in everything that you do
by doing one thing practicing every
single day
because it's a muscle the ritual of over
delivering
don't just give your customers what they
expect give them
10x more than what they expect don't
just give your organization
what your manager what your boss what
the organization is expecting from you
show something that is so rare in
today's economy
initiative initiative so
you're asked to do a project give them
five more things than they expect
you're asked to give a presentation on
something go the extra mile
consistently dial in the daily habit
of over delivering on people's
expectations and guess what
you become a merchant of wow you become
indispensable to your organization i
wrote a book a little while ago called
the greatness guide and one of the
chapters talked about
the importance of being indispensable
and i learned that when i was a young
lawyer and i remember talking to my
mentor
and i asked my mentor you know the top
litigator at this firm how come
he is the icon of the legal profession
in this region and my mentor looked at
me and said robin
because that person is indispensable to
this firm
well how do you do that by practicing
the ritual of
over delivering every single day for the
rest of your life
bill gates was asked what was the
winning formula
of microsoft when microsoft was really
the heavyweight champion of
their industry i think they're a little
lost right now
but the larger point again is he
replied with this what made
microsoft microsoft was not our
software what made microsoft
microsoft was our hiring
i just want to suggest to you the second
point
or trait of a world class company
is their ability to hire a players here
is the brain tattoo i want you to
absolutely hardwire
in to your business philosophy as a
leader
you cannot build an a level company
with c level talent if your company is
not winning
in your field right now you likely have
weaknesses
in your hiring don't just hire people
because it's the easiest move to make
a lot of companies spend very little
time on hiring and then most of
their time managing their hiring
mistakes and you know if you're building
a business if you're an entrepreneur if
you're a manager
if you're a ceo like a lot of the people
who watch these mastery sessions
and come to my live events you know i'm
speaking truth
here so you really want to nail you're
hiring
i've been evangelizing one particular
message
for two decades and it's you can lead
without a title
you know the seduction of society is
that you have to have
formal power to make a difference and
that's just a lie
the world has sold us the reality is you
can lead without a title and really the
difference
or the defining trait of a leader is
you shift from victimhood see victims
love making excuses and if you recite
your excuses long enough you actually
think they're going to be true i see it
around the world you know
people saying these things like i don't
have time to run or i don't
i'm not good enough to be great of my
work or this would never work or i don't
live in the right country or life is
hard and the more you recite those
excuses you think they're true so
let go of your excuses start getting
some results done and over time you're
going to rise to your world class
be yourself everyone else is taken
well that really speaks to the power of
being an original
it speaks to this concept of
authenticity
being yourself i mean we live in a world
where
there's never been so much of a
seduction to be like everyone else
there's never been so much influence and
hypnosis through the social media
and through society to talk in a work
certain way
to walk in a certain way to buy certain
things to measure your success
by the same philosophy and what i'm
encouraging you to do
based on this oscar wilde quote is to be
yourself
i mean talk your talk walk your walk
take the time to reflect on your dream
be true to your own values because
life's greatest heartbreak
is self-betrayal make your eye can
more important than even your iq now
you're saying robin what are you talking
about right here
well a lot of people get stuck in
victimhood versus
leadership by the seduction of saying
well i'm not smart enough
i'm not intelligent enough well
you are intelligent enough what's even
more important is your
mindset of possibility you see
if you look at the best athletes in the
world the best musicians in the world
the best entrepreneurs in the world the
best
managers in the world the best ceos in
the world the best coders in the world
the best pizza makers in the world the
best moms and pops
etc etc etc those who get
elite level results are not the most
intelligent
or naturally gifted people in their
field but these are the people that have
that mindset of
possibility and it's all about i can
and that might sound like a bit of a
platitude you know
having a an attitude if i can a mindset
of
possibility a mentality of legendary
but when you really deconstruct it it's
really true
the way you begin each day sets up the
way you live
each day i mean the spartan warriors
said it so well
sweat more in training bleed less in war
and if you want to be literally
undefeatable in business
literally unstoppable in life
you really want to dial in your morning
routine
and so you want to do things like
starting the day sweating
because that releases bdnf brain derived
neurotrophic factor
that repairs brain cells from stress you
want to sweat because that's going to
increase your metabolic rate which is
going to give you
energy and we live in a world where
energy is even more valuable
than intelligence you want to in your
morning routine
take the time to write in a journal so
you actually can detect your values
reconnect with your goals each day get
to know yourself even more
because awareness is the beginning of
transformation
and you want to get your morning routine
right so you take some time at the front
end of your day
to learn because as you learn more you
know you're going to achieve
more and as you understand better you
can achieve larger
for the past number of years i've been
reading obituaries
and you might say robin that's negative
and i don't think it's negative i think
it's really positive
because i think few things are as
powerful to wake you up to remind you
about what's most important
to fuel your energy to get you into the
game
so you let go of your fears and you do
what you need to do
to get big things done than connecting
to your own mortality
when you realize that every single day
could be your last or when you
appreciate that no matter how long you
live
life is a short ride you just sort of
let go of the fears and you let go the
limits and you live
full-on and you seize opportunities and
you
have real conversations with real people
and you sort of wear your heart on your
sleeve and you bring on the fullness of
your authenticity and you do whatever it
takes to get your loftiest dreams
to get done and so i read these
obituaries and it reminds me
about what life is all about and
relatively recently i've started walking
in cemeteries i was in mauritius
a little while ago it's i don't know if
you've been to mauritius but it's this
paradise on earth it's this tiny island
about four hours off the coast of cape
town and i've been to mauritius a number
of times i was there to give a big
leadership event you know i talked about
leading without a title
so it was filled with iconic ceos and
people running big industries and big
companies and entrepreneurs
and startup people
and it was really wonderful but i also
took about a week and a half
just to refuel and to work on my new
book and to reconnect with my values and
to set myself up for the coming months
and
one of the things i did was i went for a
long walk
i love walking i find interesting like i
find a lot of the most creative people
the most productive people
in the planet they all have one thing in
common they have the routine of walking
on a regular basis
and so i love walking i've walked in
nature for many many years
and so here i am in mauritius and i just
started walking
and i was actually listening to an
interview of charlie rose
and steve martin and it was done in new
york in front of an audience of a few
thousand people
it was about an hour and a half long and
steve martin was talking about his
career and charlie rose is one of the
great interviewers of our time
so he was asking about how he became so
good at what he did
and his life and his love of art and
stand-up
comedy and acting i mean he you know
steve martin became an actor after a
stand-up comedian etc
and so i'm walking and the sun is
setting and i'm walking along the
indian ocean and i'm looking at the
flowers
and i get to this little village and
it's this
really um
you know this little village with a lot
of character
and as i'm walking along the edge of the
village still close to the seaside
i spot a cemetery
and i i've learned to follow my instinct
more than ever before because instinct
is more powerful than reason
and life will lead you to an interesting
place if you
stay with the flow and so i walked
towards the cemetery
and i walked into the cemetery and i
started walking through the
cemetery very respectfully and carefully
but it was interesting to me because a
lot of the tombstones were just made of
wood
and somewhat sadly
some of the wooden crosses were actually
really really small
and you could tell that the grave sites
were of kids and as i walked through the
cemetery i saw these crosses and i saw
some tombstones some looked very old
a few graves looked fresh
and it reminded me really about
the shortness of life i mean marcus
aurelius has written one of my favorite
books
the meditations of marcus or release and
actually he didn't write it
marcus aurelius was a roman emperor and
during a long military campaign in his
journal he wrote his thoughts and his
philosophies and someone found those
diaries those journals
and made them into this book called the
meditations of marcus aurelius
and he does talk about the shortness of
life and so does
you know hepatitis and a lot of the
great stoic philosophers
and being in this cemetery and walking
through it with great
delicacy it reminded me how
short life is and it reminded me we all
have hopes and dreams and we never know
when those dreams are going to get
dashed
and you know we never know when our last
day will unfold
some people wake up tomorrow morning
they'll get in their car
you know they'll take a shower they'll
have their coffee they'll say goodbye to
their loved ones and that will be the
last day that their loved ones will ever
see them
you know some people on the planet the
day after tomorrow will go into their
doctor's office
to get the result of a routine checkup
and the doctor will say sit down i've
got some sad news for you
and they'll be diagnosed with maybe some
kind of a terminal illness
i mean accidents illness
tragedy catastrophe is also a reality of
humanity
and so what i'm suggesting to you is
do whatever it takes to be in the moment
and to stay positive and to stay on your
game
and to optimize your craft and to spend
time with your loved ones and to take
care of your fitness
and to learn something new every day and
to enjoy the beauty of sunsets and
star-filled nights
and at the same time as much as possible
please do not lose perspective
stay connected to your mortality
you know steve jobs in that famous
stanford speech
said it really well you know you are
naked
you have nothing to lose and he learned
that when he connected
to his cancer and so maybe you will
install a ritual
once a month on the way home from work
you will pull over to a cemetery and
you'll spend
five minutes even in meditation
looking at the tombstones looking at the
crosses
studying the graves or whatever your
tradition is in whatever nation you're
from because not every tradition i know
has the gravesites sometimes it's the
the funeral pyre which really
reminds me that life is really short
and you never know when your last day is
going to be
and so just build some kind of a routine
to remind you on the shortness of life
so that you
tell the people you love how you feel
about them so you
write the letters that need to be
written and i know people don't write
letters but writing a letter to someone
you need to express forgiveness to or
gratitude to
is really powerful pursue
the projects that will allow you to
be the legend of your industry chase the
passions that fuel your joy
and live every day as if it was your
last
because we never know when our last day
will show up
so for the next 90 days your first
90 minutes at work
make it focused on your single most
important project
i'll repeat that again for the next 90
days
the first 90 minutes of your work day
focus
monomaniacally on your single most
valuable
project i call it your game-changing
move so it might be
it might be creating a new piece of code
that will revolutionize the marketplace
it might be a new product that when you
launch it
will fill a need within your industry
that no
peer is currently providing i don't know
what your game changing move is
but this is your poetry this is your
magnum
opus for the next 90 days so
what most people do is you know people
who are playing at victimhood people who
are in the 95
people who are making excuses about
ordinary results in their life
a lot of them are not doing the things
that would give them legendary results
and what they do is they get to the
office and rather than using
prime time for a activities
they use their best hours watching
dancing cats
on whatever it is whatever the video
platform is
they spend their best hours surfing the
internet looking at blogs
they spend their best hours playing with
notifications reading notifications
chatting with friends who are not really
their friends but really they're just
bored so they're distracting themselves
which is just a form of medication
because potential unexpressed turns to
pain and they're in a lot of pain
and it's subconscious and they haven't
done the work to know it so really
they've
created these drugs of choice like too
much email too much web surfing too much
chit chatting too much looking at funny
looking videos
that make them laugh in the moment that
make them feel happy and give them a
short
burst of dopamine and maybe a little bit
of serotonin which is the
pleasure neurotran neurotransmitter
and that's how they get through their
day and all i'm saying is there is so
much distraction available to you out
there that if you are not
acutely careful it will dominate your
day a ritual for you to run
and dial in and hard wire to the point
of automaticity
that's the word the researchers use when
a habit becomes your new normal
over 66 days is the 1991 rule and to
give it to you again so you really
remember it
for the next 90 days your first 90
minutes
create a tight bubble of total focus so
that no one can distract you turn off
your devices put them in a little
plastic bag put some reminders on your
door maybe some post-it notes that this
is my tight bubble of total focus for
the next 90 minutes
tell your team tell your loved ones
maybe get a put a do not disturb
sign on your door they'll laugh and
explain it to them
that for the next 90 days i will spend
90 minutes away from distraction away
from technology
away from interruptions focusing on my
magnum opus
focusing on the genius project that i
want to
bring into the world because i will
never mail it in i will always bring it
on
and i'm going to do this for the next 90
minutes and i'm going to optimize it and
iterate it every day
and i'm going to bring my full bandwidth
because what makes a genius they all
have one trait in common
they were able to spend extended periods
of time
in isolation focused monomonically
on their most valuable project you've
heard me talk about
the 2x 3x mindset so to double your
income
and your impact triple your investment
including your time investment in two
core areas
your personal mastery and your
professional
capabilities you see when you work on
your personal mastery
you awaken your mindset your heart set
your health set
and your soul set and when you get those
four interior
empires to world class you become a
force of nature out in the world
and you do epic things so you want to
work on your personal mastery like
you're doing here with me right now by
listening
to this episode and then the second
thing you want to do is you want to work
on
your professional capability you want to
be the heavyweight champion
of your game you want to dial in your
sport
whether your sport is entrepreneurship
whether your sport is
being a chef whether your sport is being
a coder
whether your sport is being a manager
whether you're an entrepreneur a ceo
an astronaut a poet i don't know what it
is but when you focus on your personal
mastery and your professional capability
and you really work on those i'm talking
about hours every day if you are serious
about leading the field what starts to
happen is this
you become a vastly more valuable
person you become very aware and that's
why i say
education is inoculation against
disruption that's why i suggest you with
great love and respect
leadership belongs to the learners maya
angelou said it beautifully
she said when you know better you can do
better
with better awareness you can make
better choices
and with better choices you're going to
see better results
i mean it's the awareness that you bring
to every day based on your learning
based on your investments in training
well what does that do it gives you the
ability each day to make better choices
better decisions when you look at a
great life it's just a series of
beautiful choices done daily stacked on
over time and so when you get great
awareness
heightened awareness more acute
awareness of what it means to be a
leader
an elite performer an a player an
awesome human being
an epic producer a fit human being a
loving human
it just goes on with that awareness
via your learning you can make better
decisions every day
what makes a great company is less about
your good
opportunities and a lot more about
you having the bravery and discipline to
say
no to you to your many good
opportunities what destroys a great
company
is actually opportunity bloating
too many good opportunities so literally
you defuse
your team's bandwidth and you get
distracted and you see with so many
companies right now
they they sort of found their sweet
pocket
and they were absolutely winning in
their marketplace and they decided to go
hmm we've got this app that is really
changing the game and owning the
marketplace
let's get into food delivery let's get
into
this let's get into that it happened to
general electric as well and you
probably know
they decided at one point if we can't be
one or two in any market we're going to
get out of that market
that's the key point i'm trying to make
know your mighty mission
know your mono-maniacal focus and then
have the discipline to say
no to everything else so you can lock
and load on your finest opportunity
to completely change the game the
traits that make you strange are the
gifts that make you special
and so i know you're different because
you wouldn't be here with me now if you
didn't feel you're different
you probably don't fit in with most
conversations i sure don't fit in
with most conversations i don't know a
lot about most things
that most people talk about because i
don't participate in the majority
i don't participate in the news
i don't like to gossip i like to
encourage people
versus diminished people i like to be
productive
versus busy i like to be creative
versus complacent i like to create
value versus take from other people
i like to move into my present and
future versus
get stuck in the past i like to be
fast versus move too too too slow
i like to be a leader versus a victim
i like to believe in possibility
versus get stuck in rational thinking
because you know the
instinct is so much more powerful than
intellect and all i'm suggesting to you
is simply this it's the very things that
make you
different that make you authentic
and if you don't fit in i just want to
share with you i've never fit in
and the very nature of anyone who's
living a visionary life and you are
living a visionary life
no matter what you're doing let's not
get trapped in labels oh i'm just a
coder i'm just
a receptionist in a at a at a restaurant
or
or in an organization i'm just a yoga
teacher i'm just a gym manager i'm just
a chef
in a restaurant i'm just a teacher
people always say this when i
interact with them on the social media
i'm just
an entrepreneur i'm just a student no
you're not
i'm just a mom i'm just a dad no you're
not just you're very special
there are no extra people on the planet
today and i just want to say to you and
validate for you and encourage you
those things that other people might not
get those are
your gifts you might be awkward
awesome you see the world through a
different lens
steve wozniak who is on my stage at the
titan summit zurich the co-founder of
apple
one of the best people i've ever met he
would not have been able to create
the apple platforms and
products that he created if he didn't
see the world through a different set of
eyes
steve jobs saw the world through a
different set of eyes travis kalanick
of uber saw the world through different
set of eyes jeff bezos of amazon
saw possibility let me have an online
store that initially sells books
john f kennedy martin luther king jr
mother teresa
rosa parks jean-michel basquiat
beethoven
michelangelo who did the sistine chapel
and in florence david jonas salk
tesla we could just go on
and on and on and on these people were
misunderstood because the nature of a
genius
is to not fit in
one of the lines from right out of the
5am club is
one of the dnas of legendary is
longevity
so if you look at the picassos the
jean-michel basquiatch you look at the
great
sports champions you look at the great
history makers
they were much better at energy
management than time management
and so we're in a war against
distraction right now and what we really
have to do is
optimize our energy how do i do it well
i mean i get to the morning routine
which which
the whole book is based on but it's
really quite powerful because if you
start your day
with sweaty exercise you're actually
going to activate
a pharmacy of mastery that exists in
every human brain
i know you love the neuroscience you're
going to release bdnf which is
brain-derived neurotrophic factor
that's going to actually accelerate your
processing it's actually going to repair
brain cells that have been damaged by
stress you're going to release the
neurotransmitter dopamine which is the
the fire neurotransmitter which we all
need as entrepreneurs and business
builders and
and servants of humanity cortisol
the fear hormone is highest in the
morning so
exercising first thing in the morning is
going to reduce that i'm getting into my
20 20 20 formula but i mention it
because it is a way to maximize your
energy
and we live in a world where a lot of
people this is right out of the book an
addiction to distraction is the death of
creative production
there are a lot of cyber zombies on the
planet there are a lot of people on the
planet right now
giving the best hours of their finest
days to
the white screen of attractions
and i i really think that betraying your
genius every single person on the planet
has primal genius within them that's
scientifically proven
we can talk about it i go into it in the
book but playing with your phone versus
pursuing your monuments of
mastery is betraying not only yourself i
think it's betraying the world and so
i really believe and i've experienced it
for two decades with my clients getting
up at 5 a.m and running this calibrated
20 20 20 formula
that much of the book is about will take
any human being to a new level of
creativity
productivity prosperity and service to
humanity
you know i i think marie life's greatest
heartbreak
is being untrue to yourself and
i come from very humble beginnings i
have a great
family and yet the people around me said
if you become a lawyer like i basically
had a choice become an
engineer a doctor or a lawyer and so
i followed through on that and i went to
law school and
i became a really successful litigation
lawyer
and i had you know a nice place to live
and i had a nice car and i was making
great money and people said i'm on
you're on your way to being a judge and
yet i would wake up every morning and i
would
look at myself in the bathroom mirror
and i didn't like or even know
the person who was looking back at me
and
that i love that word angst you know
that angst just got to a point where i
said i
had to make some changes and so i
started listening to that
silent whisper of my heart you know
there's there's something
i believe in which is instinct is much
more powerful and wiser than intellect
and i think when all of us trust our
intel our
instinct in a world that says intellect
and logic is everything
we we start to enter what mr riley in
the 5am club calls the magic and
that's sort of what happened to me i
find your destiny doesn't knock it
whispers
and so it wasn't this epiphany you know
it was just
um i think when you start to trust your
instinct
and trust yourself versus the world and
you sort of block out the opinions of
other people
the pace of synchronicity starts to open
up and these doors that you're supposed
to walk through start to present
themselves to you
one of the things about the 95 percent a
lot of them are complaining they're
making excuses they want epic lives
but they're stuck in the group of super
the cult of superficiality
the top five percent the titans the
icons the a players
the world builders are very different
they are not about superficiality they
are all about granularity
literally they have deseeded the lemon
wedges this is a metaphor that i teach
basically i was at a at a hotel in
luzerne switzerland
and i love fresh lemon tea and when they
brought the tray to me
i noticed that in the tray
was two lemon halves or and someone in
the kitchen had taken the time to
de-seed the lemon wedges
they actually deseeded them and when i
studied f1 teams and i actually had the
privilege to be right with the team
at a recent f1 and what i realized is
f1 almost like no other sport is really
about de-seeding the lemon wedges
it was the smallest granular detail
the smallest calibration
that could make the difference between
a top one and a tenth place finish i
really want you to think about that
i really want you to think about f1 f1
is one
or lost in milliseconds because
each lap if you get a little bit faster
and you do it with the consistency
because consistency is the mother of
mastery
that is the difference between first
place
and not even placing and so if you look
at the top five percent
they are all about deseeding the lemon
wedges if you look at the top five
percent
they're all about calibration and people
might misunderstand you and say
are you obsessive why do the details
matter and all you have to do is smile
and say because the details matter and
if you study beyonce
study the great athletes you study the
great f1 drivers and teams
they do deseed the lemon wedges they do
calibrate
the pomodoro they get oad that brain
tattoo i become really well known across
the planet for
an obsessive attention to detail
oad that's what makes the best hotels
the best
entrepreneurs the best teams the market
leaders
the best restaurants the best hotels the
best cars
the best products the best user
experiences online
they are sweating the tiniest seemingly
innocuous
innocuous details to create over time
a user experience that creates a global
base of fanatical followers number three
unbelievably important
which is the importance of scheduling
you know i talk a lot
a lot about having a dream having a plan
you know being inspired
but all ideas don't work unless you do
the work and some of the best work you
can do is getting really good
at creating a one page plan have your
big five the five things that need to
happen this year for this to be your
best year yet
on a one page plan your top five values
put them on that same plan
your top five sub goals sequenced into
each quarter of this year
on that one page plan and every morning
while your competition or the rest of
the world is asleep
get up at 5am i'll teach you how to do
that in future videos
but look at your one page plan spend 20
minutes on that
so it becomes a brain tattoo a burning
obsession so it alights you with
inspiration
so you go out in the world and you
understand that clarity is power
and you so intimately know what has to
happen during this day
this week this month this quarter this
year to get you closer to your
mountaintop
because the ordinary the hours that
ordinary people waste
extraordinary people do because they're
not bored like most people
most people need to medicate themselves
with too much tv too much
facebook too much video too much
chitchat too much
busyness because they don't know their
goals because they don't have a one-page
plan
because they don't have a one-page
schedule i mean i've got
my schedule for every seven days almost
everything i need to do
goes on it and you might say robin well
that's a very rigid way to live no it's
a very free way to live
because then i have the power to live
life on my own terms i feel inspired
i'm not wasting each day i'm leveraging
each day
become outrageously enthusiastic
and again you're going to say robin
let's hold hands and sing kumbaya
you know being enthusiastic isn't
important next thing you're going to
tell me is get up in the morning and
look in the mirror and saying
i think i am i think i am i like myself
i like myself i like myself i like
myself
[Music]
but isn't it true that the most
enthusiastic
person in the room influences people
and they elevate people and they
encourage people another issue of
fortune magazine a little while ago did
a
did a story on richard branson's necker
island conference
he invited all sorts of amazing people
and the reporter in the room said
something i've never forgotten
the reporter said it was striking to me
how in each of the conference sessions
the moguls of these giant firms
were always the most enthusiastic people
in the rooms it's amazing to me when i
meet world-class
ceos they are the most humble
the most passionate they are the most
engaged
they're the most lively people in the
room
i think it's fundamentally important to
be the most enthusiastic person you know
i think in so many ways leadership is
about inspiring people by your example
persistency versus the short game
we do live in a world where everything
just happens so
fast that if we have a project or a
cause or a mission
if it doesn't happen instantly
or if it doesn't manifest or materialize
the way we want it within a month or
within a quarter
even within a year we give up
and we then start chasing the next shiny
toy
of opportunity so i was in piazza novona
in rome a few weeks ago working on a new
book
and i love piazza navona because it's
one of the most beautiful squares on the
planet
and when i'm in my creative cycle i go
there
just to refuel and if you walk into
piazza navona what you're going to see
is i think it's called the four rivers
sculpture by bernini
and the point i'm trying to make to you
is as i looked at this
masterpiece of a sculpture what i
realized is
the true masters are not all about
impatience
they're not all about the short game
they
understand that world class
is a process and that genius could take
decades and what makes rare air
output is the ability to stick with a
singular vision of your masterpiece
whatever that is a great company a great
family
a gorgeous life a new book a film i
don't know
but mastery comes through deep
focus patience and persistency and when
i looked at bernini's
sculpture you could see the level of
detail
you know and so few people have it it
really is a gargantuan competitive
advantage a gc
what i teach in my work as a gca a
gargantuan competitive advantage because
most people don't have patience anymore
most people
do not have the grit and the resolve
to stay with a sculpture that's a
metaphor for you their sculpture
for maybe a year on just a little piece
and maybe the next piece of your
sculpture another year or two years you
know it took
22 years to build the taj mahal but it
became one of the seven wonders of the
world
that's a metaphor for you that i really
want you to think about
there's a reason why the visionary
founder of starbucks
howard schultz rises before the sun
there's a reason
why michelle obama rises very early
there's a reason why
tim cook who's leading apple gets up
before the dawn first of all the hours
between four and six are the time of
least distraction in this age of
dramatic
interruption number two the hours before
the sun rises is the period where
your brain is most available to your
primary creativity so while you're
sleeping your brain actually washes
itself but also it lets
it go off the residue of the previous
day while you are
resting and while you are recovering
when you wake up
your thinking is fresh your creativity
is most pristine you are most
available to access
your gifts and your talents so those are
some of the reasons why i encourage you
to get a brill you might say robin well
i'm not an early riser i can't put mind
over mattress i can't win the battle of
the bed grandma i never got up early
dad couldn't get up early i guess i'm
not the kind of person who can rise
before the sun
and what i would suggest to you is
simply this
what science confirms in particular the
data
of university college london you do any
new habit practice it for 66 days
and you will arrive at the place of
automaticity in other words it'll be
easier to run the new habit than not to
66 days of rising at 5 a.m
will get you to a place where it's
easier to get up to 5 am
then not to get up at 5 00 a.m you'll
reach a place of automaticity
in my book the 5am club i say all change
is hard at
first and it's messy in the middle and
it's gorgeous
at the end i'll repeat that again
because it's so important all change is
hard at first
messy in the middle and it's gorgeous at
the end in the book there's
a chapter on the habit installation
process
that actually explains the three phases
every habit goes through before you wire
it into
the place where it's automatic number
one destruction
number two integration and number three
implementation really important to
remember them
so you can get up early you can
install habits as a matter of fact
neuroplasticity which is the phenomenon
that speaks to the fact the brain is
like a muscle the more you flex
it and push it the more it's going to
grow you have that gift
it's not just for federer and serena
williams and oprah winfrey and
shakespeare and joe michelle
at and steve jobs and elon musk
you have a brain that
has the capability to grow and adapt
so what is the 20 20 20 formula that
lies at the core of the 5 am club method
while the first 20 minutes move sweat
you'll release bdnf brain derived
neurotrophic factor which will increase
the neural connections of your brain
as well as repair brain cells damaged by
stress
and also promote neurogenesis which is
the formation of new
brain cells i know this is a lot of
information but i want to
give you great content in this video
exercising for 20 minutes first thing
the morning from 5 to 5
20. the first part of the 20 20 20
formula
releases dopamine which is the
inspirational neurotransmitter how
valuable is that for your creativity and
productivity for the rest of the day
cortisol the fear hormone is highest
first thing in the morning
exercising will reduce it serotonin is
released so you'll feel happier
now it's 5 20 you're full of energy
you've optimized your cognition
your focus is increasing it's only 5 20
the rest of the world is asleep just
imagine that advantage you already have
second pocket for the 20 20 20 formula
is all about reflection we live in a
world where people don't reflect anymore
a lot of people are busy
being busy but what's the point of being
busy around the wrong things
so for 20 minutes from 5 20 to 5 40 you
reflect you pray or write in a journal
you meditate you can visualize you can
script out a blueprint
for a great day ahead which habit
researchers call a pre-commitment
strategy which actually increases your
willpower and your ability to get your
most
important priorities done okay now it's
5
40 from 5 40 to 6 o'clock this is the
final 20 minute pocket
of the 20 20 20 formula the first pocket
was about move
the second is reflected the third is
grow i've coached billionaires
and ceos and nba superstars and members
of royalty for over 20 years
here's what i realized when i work with
the best of the best
they love to learn they love to grow
they don't see investing in yourself or
investing in your skills or investing in
your growth
a cost they think about the value
received
i call it the 2x 3x mindset to double
your
income and your impact triple your
investment in two core areas
your personal mastery and your
professional
capability so for 20 minutes what do you
do you
listen to a podcast you review your
journal notes you read a book
you watch a valuable video you just do
something you read an autobiography you
do
something to grow your capacities
and materialize more of the potential
you have been born into
and now at six o'clock you've optimized
your mindset
you've purified your heart set you've
calibrated your health set you've
escalated your soul set
you feel fundamentally different in the
5am club there's another
model called the four habits of history
makers and
one of the elements is day stacking the
whole idea is simply this get your
mornings right
your days are going to be fundamentally
more energetic creative productive and
high impact
and a great week is nothing worse than a
series of great
days and a great month is the same thing
and a great quarter is just a
series of well-lived weeks and it just
continues
and creates this upward spiral of
success just by getting from 5am to 6am
your victory hour to world class every
morning
consistency really is the mother of
mastery and own your morning you're
really going to elevate
your life when something doesn't work
out during your day
and you get discouraged you lose your
fire
ask yourself this question what's the
opportunity here
that's what wtoh stands for what's the
opportunity here
what i've realized is when things don't
work out
the victim says oh boohoo poor me
they get stuck in sadness
or anger or regret and some of them
spend the rest of their life in that
state what the leader does is this
you feel the pain you notice the
disappointment you never want to
suppress that that would
build up the toxic emotions within you
so feel the just disappointment
if it's you know you forgot your keys
somewhere
you lost your wallet you missed the
train
you missed a meeting you lost a sale
or maybe it's something heavier
you just got your heart broken you just
lost your job
uh you just got some negative news from
your doctor at your annual
checkup i mean that's one of the things
that happens in life we all face
very hard times when those things happen
feel the emotion do not suppress it
because the quickest way out of the
painful or sad emotions is straight in
but here's the real key ask yourself
what's the opportunity here
how can i use this small or
large negative event
to grow how can i use this situation
to give me more wisdom to give me more
acumen
to make me more experienced how can i
use this situation
to strengthen me and fortify me how can
i use this situation to become more
authentic
and more real because it's the difficult
things in life that crack open our
social mask
and allow us to be more real and more
authentic how can i use this situation
to build my relatability so i'm more
relatable to human beings and ultimately
how can i
use this situation as fuel to make my
life
even better if you keep if you simplify
versus go complex
what happens is you can then take your
energy
and your focus and your personal
resources
and focus them on the few things that
will be most important and that's what
the great ones do
they marshall and harness their
resources their
mental focus their physical energy their
personal willpower
their individual gifts their time i call
those the five
assets of elite performance and they
focus them on just a few things and if
you i want you to think about it in your
life
if you stripped away all the noise you
focused on the signal
you stripped away all the complexity you
got monomially concentrated on just a
few things
of course you'd be brilliant at those
few things all
genius has a dark side so whether it's a
beethoven
or a buffett whether it's a federer or
serena williams whether
it is a jean-michel basquiat
or a feron adria
the things that allow for genius
all have a downside or a dark side
here's
some examples someone who is
absolutely brilliant at execution has a
dark side to manage
of impatience someone like steve jobs
who is a fanatical perfectionist
could be seen as demanding someone who
is amazingly creative could
self-sabotage with too many ideas the
key is this
honor your gift manage the downside
the vast majority of people what they do
is they
are pursuing things they derive their
power by what they have in the world
they want
they measure success by more money and a
larger house and a faster car
and more social status but if you look
at the
so-called great ones the history makers
who have shaped
humanity they really are in an alternate
universe or
another orbit they're really not fueled
by the things that most people are
chasing when i look at
a nelson mandela for example what i've
realized is
through their interior work you know my
four interior empires mindset
heart set health set and soul set
and so through his interior work to
build his interior
internal character nelson mandela got to
a level of maturity that most people
just don't get to why because most
people are so
outer focused and building exterior
lives
and it's not so hip and cool and stylish
anymore
to build vast and undefeatable interior
lives
but he did and maybe it was a lot of his
time
through the suffering of 27 years of
incarceration maybe it was the 18 years
that he spent in isolation on robben
island
the point really is through his personal
excavation through his reflection
through his prayer
through his contemplation for so many
years he built a vast interior
reservoir of strength and creativity
and true versus fake power that
created an inner life of incredible
maturity
and so the first point really is do
whatever it takes
to build a life of such maturity where
it's not about your ego
but it's about lifting the world
and that's incredibly powerful because
if you base your power
on things should you lose those things
you lose your power you're in a really
vulnerable place
but if you derive your power and your
self-worth
and your sense of self from who you are
your moral authority your sense of
creativity
your your ability to love yourself
your knowledge of the fullness of the
gifts that you were born into if that's
where your identity comes from
then your world could fall apart and you
still say stay strong so
first point work on your maturity level
so you get to a place where it's not
about
me it's about we work on your
maturity so you're not deriving
your strength in the world
from external things but you're getting
it from your internal
uh character or your internal life you
have a responsibility to manage yourself
you know sometimes people say well my
boss is grumpy and
cranky and doesn't really appreciate me
one of the key ideas
is people don't leave companies they
leave the people they worked with you've
heard that before
that's not my idea that's out there but
the point on leader lead thyself is
you're responsible for managing your
mindset your heart set
your health set your soul set every time
you blame
your boss or your husband or your wife
your past or your children the economy
or your nationality you're giving away
your power
to be the change you want to see to use
the words of mahatma gandhi
with our customers my team
runs a protocol called the 10x value
obsession
how can we deliver 10 times the value
at every single touch point of the user
experience
that our customers come to the live
events or go into my online course
or even read my books are expecting they
pay twenty dollars for a book or thirty
dollars for a book
how can i give them millions of dollars
of real value someone said to me
recently
in your mastery sessions you're giving
away the store
or something like that you know like i
sort of can't believe
how much value you give and my reply was
because my intent is to serve
i mean this is not a business for me yes
i run a business
and a series of businesses i'm an
entrepreneur
but the point really is my
intent is so much larger than that i'm
on a mission
bordering on an obsession to help
everyday people
understand the neurobiology of greatness
and they can lead without a title if
you've read my book the leader had no
title
that they have heroism in them and then
giving them the
neuroscience the research the
performance data that will help them win
in their careers live great lives live
their potential
this is so much more than a business for
me and this comes from value number two
i see this as a movement a sense of
community
a sense of giving a sense of helping you
fortify
the genius within you in a very
difficult world so you say
huh robin has given me thousands of
ideas
in these free mastery sessions that i
can choose to act on
every day to go out there and fire proof
my
heroism i can do great work that wows
the world
do great things for my family and leave
an impact
on history that stands the test of time
and if i do that
in my own way that i've served you and
i've done my job well eighth rule
for a monumental life is get great at
your craft
look you have a gargantuan competitive
advantage because most people are caught
up
or card-carrying members and i say this
with respect but it's reporting
reality most people in the world right
now in business
are card carrying members of the cult of
mediocrity
in a previous episode and i share this
in my leadership presentations i believe
the world today is suffering and that
word i'm choosing it
consciously and carefully from the
collective deprofessionalization of
business
a little while ago i was in an airport
there was a
elevator repairman and he had his boom
box
cranking out hard rock well that's fine
but
he's at work he's not at home i go into
a store these days
there are people listening to music out
loud
when they should be taking care of
customers
you walk into an airport and you see
people behind the desk or whatever
rather than being
pros owning the game you literally see
them chit chatting or again
looking at videos of dancing cats
and people riding bicycles off the roofs
of their houses you know what i'm
talking about
i call it the collective
de-professionalization of business very
few people relatively speaking right now
say this is my craft i've got to be a
pro
i've got to study the audiobooks that
relate to my game
i've gotta find mentors i've gotta read
the books
i've gotta practice like federer or
serena williams
or muhammad ali used to practice you
know what muhammad ali once said
he said i hated every single one of
those early morning runs
but i loved the idea of being champion
of the world so one of my brain tattoos
that i've become very well known for
is no one will believe in you until you
believe in you
and so good people often become seduced
by the chatter of their loudest fears
and what i mean by that is
we come up with a great idea let's say
it's to start a project that will allow
you to lead your field
let's say it's an idea for a new product
that will allow you to grow new company
let's say you come up with an idea for a
new painting if you are
an artist let's say it's an idea that
will allow you
to take your fitness and your wellness
and your longevity to a whole new level
of wow
and pretty shortly after you come up
with the idea
your ego starts screaming because
we we are good in our comfort zones but
the moment we start to go blue
ocean around our next level of mastery
our fears come up because we're going
out into the unknown it's human
you know if you look to look at the
psychobiology of it
and you were studying the pure biology
effort there's a term called homeostasis
human beings
are hardwired for a steady state and
that kept us alive
so literally our heart beats around the
same amount you know the 72 beats per
minute
and our blood pressure is within a small
bandwidth
and that allows us to survive but what
happens is when we come up with a new
idea and when we see a new opportunity
and we start to leave our comfort zones
into the zone of the unknown
where greatness lives we get scared
and the true heroes and the true titans
and the true masters
those people are not fearless those are
people who have just
practiced walking into their fear
and living on the razor's edge
consistently
to the point where they're comfortable
amid their discomfort
and that's the great opportunity for you
not to avoid fear
but to be comfortable in the unknown to
be comfortable
when you're terrified and that really is
what the great artists the great
entrepreneurs the great titans and the
great masters
are very good on doing so the first
reason good people
lose is their faith is not as strong
as their fear or to put it a bit more
elegantly their
fears are larger than their faith and so
it would be tactical for you how do you
build more faith well you
you do what you're frightened to do
and it's a practice you know a great
athlete practices every morning
and a great producer practices
walking into their fears every single
day
and what i'm encouraging you to do is
every single day do
one thing that causes your palms to
sweat
every single day start training your
brain to hunt for opportunities
to step into that unknown where
possibility lives and if you keep on
doing it
you're literally going to build some new
neurological
hardwiring a new mental a new pathway in
your brain
where you become it becomes easier
because as you know so well all change
is hard at first and it's messy in the
middle and it's beautiful at the end
you want to if you want to have a
world-class company release
only magic another way i could put it
only release sistine chapel ceiling
level products to the world
steve jobs said it beautifully he said i
wanted the icons on the iphone
to be so beautiful people would want to
lick the screen
i had a senior leader show up at one of
my leadership events and he said you
know robin
steve jobs was like that i actually went
to his house and met him
shortly before he died and he didn't
look very well
but he didn't want to talk about his
physical condition
he just wanted to talk about the product
we were launching he was so
monominically focused on the user
experience
he literally wanted everything to be
flawless
that was steve jobs brilliance and
obsession
i saw an incredible interview with
johnny ive
by charlie rose and in that johnny ive
who you know is the design genius behind
a lot of the apple products
he said you know i knew steve jobs and i
were spiritual brothers when we were
in a a store one day and steve jobs said
to me he goes hey
come on over johnny you got to see this
and i believe from the
interview i believe this is what they
said but they were looking at an arrow
and steve jobs said
look at how the sharp point of the arrow
is attached to this part and look how
seamless it is
and look at the engineering and i wonder
how
they did that and johnny ives said steve
jobs was just in the pocket
of the engineering and beauty behind
that piece of artistry they were looking
at i remember being in soho new york
and i walked into one of the stores and
i bought a coat and i was leaving
uh on an airplane for home later that
day and i asked the person who was
taking care of me i said
is it possible that's a great respectful
way to ask for something
is it possible to get this coat
hemmed and adjust it a little bit for me
and he's
and and i said the thing is that i'm
leaving
later today and he looked at me and i've
never forgotten it because we all have
these people in our lives who say one
thing or show up in a certain way
and they stay with us for the rest of
their our lives
and he said to me these words he said
it i'd love to do that for you
i'd love to do that for you
and again the whole brain tattoo i'm
trying to deconstruct here
is make your eye can larger than your iq
you know i remember being in prague and
i asked someone on the other
again i spent a lot of time in hotels
and
i said is it possible to do this and
here was the
reply on the other end of the phone i
think something from the front desk or
maybe it was room service and i try to
eat as clean as possible
so probably it was a request could i
have olive oil and fresh lemon or lemon
as the salad dressing and here's the
reply
just to really lovingly and respectfully
and hopefully
fluently and elegantly bring this
leadership insight home to you
i said is this possible and his reply
was
anything is possible so
it's really easy to get
seduced and stuck into
a mindset of can't you know someone says
let's start a new business someone says
here's a great
poetic project that if we release it to
the world
will help us own our marketplace and it
sounds very obvious again
but ask yourself this is your default
reply
a symptom of a mindset of can't or do
you have a mentality of
possibility when someone says here read
this book do you shift into
can't or can when someone says hey you
know what
i'm amped to run a marathon you'll go i
can't is that your default
setting in your neurobiological
hardwiring
or do you go absolutely or i'd love to
do this you know it's really really
important and that is one of the core
distinctions of leadership isn't it
and i'm going to get right into the
first rule which is
leader lead thyself
so leadership is not just for ceos
leadership is not just for
prime ministers and presidents and
people with large
bank accounts and massive offices
leadership is not only an opportunity
but the responsibility of every man
woman and child on the planet today no
matter what it is you do
whether you're a filmmaker a startup
entrepreneur
a manager of a corporation a bread
creator or whatever it's called baker i
guess i'll be a baker
whether you're a teacher whether you're
a firefighter whether you're
a politician whether you are a gardener
whether you are a wall maker i don't
know whatever it is you do
but every day you walk out in the world
gives you not only that opportunity
but brings with it the awesome
responsibility
to show up as a leader because
leadership
really isn't a title you know my book
the leader who had no title you've
probably read it
leadership is less about a title and
it's more about
an approach a way of being and some of
the traits of leaders without titles
they're radiant optimists in a world
gone
cynical one of the things about leaders
without titles
they don't see their job as a job they
see their job as a craft
no matter what their work is they
understand there's dignity
in all labor one of the traits of
leaders without titles
they are relentlessly improving
everything they
touch so they leave it better than they
found it
and so the first rule for monumental
life is simply leader lead thyself
which just means see yourself as a
leader and don't wait for the people
around you to start leading
lead where you're planted lead by
example
you stand up first be an army of
one when it comes to leadership and
spreading that leadership
possibility around you rule number four
to thine own self be true you're gonna
say robin that sounds sort of familiar
of course it's shakespeare
to thine own self be true you know oscar
wilde said it so much more elegantly
than i ever could he said
be yourself everyone else is taken
you know jack welsh when he was a
general electric one of our clients ge
he said never lose yourself on the way
to the top wow
what amazing advice for you and me
never lose yourself on the way to the
top to though
to thine own self be true never betray
your authenticity
never lose your boots on the
groundedness
divine self be true means as you make
your rise to legendary
don't forget what makes you great
hard work humility
serving your customers working on your
craft
playing the long game understanding the
genius takes
decades versus good genetics
the bow too tightly strung as easily
broken
says one of the proverbs balance is a
gorgeous thing
so be mono maniacal in your execution
around your
high value targets your hvts
your mission plan but also
build in some rewards that's going to
send a gorgeous message to your
conscious and your subconscious mind
that hey
this daily practice of execution around
my deliverables
is a beautiful thing and you create this
thing called momentum
and the monk who sold his ferrari i went
back and i saw this recently
i think there's a whole chapter on
momentum and you become like this
i love skiing you start off small but as
you go down the slope
you pick up momentum a lot of people say
robin where do i start i want to start a
new business i want to
become a better artist i want to find
the love of my life i want to be a
world-class creative i want to
multiply my financial life where do i
start
you just start you just start there's
great power
in the start before you go to sleep
ask yourself this question did i live
out
my plan for today your days are your
life in miniature
all you need to do is not worry about
the next week the next month the next
year
forget about that that's a waste of time
own
your day your days are your life in
miniature
as you live each day so you craft the
rest of your life
and the days slip into weeks the weeks
become months the months become
years before you know it you've lived a
legendary
life because all you did was dial into
gorgeous brilliant
productive creative loving healthy
soulful days your days are the pockets
and
instruments of genius get those
right your life will take care of itself
don't live your life on the outside to
fill these holes on the inside
that you haven't filled start the
interior work of self-mastery
to fill the holes so your mindset heart
set health set
and soul set are full and then you'll
feel joy
when you wake up every morning and
you'll work not for the money but for
the meaning
and you'll create with a fire in your
belly that will make you undefeatable
it's not because you're pursuing income
it's because you're pursuing
impact and craft and love
of you honoring the genius within you
do you see what i'm referring to your
outer life you still might work
hard i love working hard i love it
but i'm not doing it for the money i'm
doing it because of who i am i have to
write
i have to serve i have to use the rest
of my life to be an
instrument of impact for as many people
as possible
leadership is much less a title and much
more
an approach to going through life and so
when you walk out in the world every day
i just want you to keep that in mind as
much as possible
you can behave like a leader with which
is
assuming personal responsibility for
your results
or you can be like a victim which is
something bad happens or something
doesn't quite work out and you give away
your power
and you blame and you complain and you
become
toxic and right now the world has far
too many victims people who are
rather than looking in the mirror saying
i have the power to change
and i might not like where i'm at in my
work right now
or in my life or in my health or in my
love or
in my spirituality but i have the power
to change well
victims say i might not be where i'm at
in the world
but it's because of the world it's
because of my childhood it's because of
my husband my wife my boss
my team my country my economy and so
my loving encouragement to you is ask
yourself right now
am i behaving like a victim maybe it's
in your
health life maybe it's with your
finances you know and a victim would be
saying
you know i can't do this
that's what victims do i can't do this
or victims
they point fingers well it's the economy
where i live right now or
it's the industry it's going through a
lot of commoditization and a lot of
disruption and if i was in a different
industry i'd be successful
ultimately we all know this we create a
reality
and even in the most difficult and most
competitive of industries
there are people who are playing at
world class who are doing really well
why because they have a different
approach because they are doing
different things
and fundamentally they're not behaving
like victims blaming and complaining
and being toxic and wasting time and
living in the past
they're showing up like leaders so be a
leader in all that you do today
step number two in the process of
structuring or creating
this world-class life your five
non-negotiable
values really important to look at your
values what are values
values are what you're going to value as
you go through your days as you go
through your weeks as you go through
your life
values could be what a mind i value
beauty
so i want to be around beauty as much as
possible i love
art galleries i love nature i love
sunset
i love looking at the stars i love
beautiful food
simply prepared with people who i love i
love beautiful conversations i love
beautiful books because a home with a
large library is a wonderful home
to be in so step number two in this
process to set yourself up for a
spectacular life
what are your five non-negotiable values
maybe it's you'll be around beauty every
day
maybe it's no matter what the situation
is i will always live with integrity
maybe one of your non-negotiable values
will be
i will exercise even when i don't feel
like it
maybe one of your non-negotiable values
will be
family first i don't know these are just
some things that i want you to think
about
you may have read my book the monk who
sold his ferrari
sometimes i speak about ferraris because
i don't have a ferrari
but i love the way that ferrari rolls
and here's what i mean by that
a ferrari is in many ways mobile
art on four tires
a ferrari in so many ways is the
distillation of
enzo ferrari's philosophy on mastery
a ferrari in so many ways is a reminder
to you
and me about what world class stands for
and what i want to really dial into
today is this did you know that every
year
ferrari only produces 7 000
ferraris and the point of wisdom or the
powerful idea
i want you to really think about and
deconstruct in your journal tonight
after this mastery session
is why go really wide when you can be
singularly deep i'm going to repeat that
again
but a great company and a great
performer
goes really really deep on one or two
things and that's how you
rise to iconic we live in a world i call
it the cult of superficiality
addicted to distraction afflicted by
interruption
so we take the trinity of our
performance assets
our mental focus our physical energy
and our willpower those are the three
primary assets of a world-class producer
and we diffuse them we disperse them
around
thousands of projects lots of little
things and yet i think of
the 7 000 ferrari philosophy you know
they are world class and
in terms of producing iconic automobiles
vehicles
but they don't want to be they don't
appeal to everyone
they don't produce hundreds of thousands
of vehicles
they want to do a few products
they want to bring out a few things but
do them
really really well and that's really the
craftsman's mindset
that's how craftsmen think or crafts
women it's do a few things but do them
really really well
and related to that is this you are an
artist
my invitation to you is to produce
poetry in terms of your work
that the world reveals as mastery
you know and that is really all about
bringing rigor to your game
it's not about doing a lot of things
it's about doing one thing well
because the secret of genius is not
complexity the secret of genius
is simplicity you look at any genius
entrepreneur you look at any genius
producer you look at any genius
athlete they're not doing five sports
they're doing
one sport incredibly well and then
putting in the training time
to be monomaniacally focused so that
they can
become otherworldly brilliant at their
one thing
and i guess what i'm suggesting to you
ultimately is this
think about the 7 000 ferrari's
philosophy
and if you are a business builder let's
say you're a startup entrepreneur
let's say you're a fortune 500 manager
let's say you're a professional athlete
because a lot of professional athletes
are watching these mastery sessions
let's say you are a mother father a yoga
teacher or a chef
what are the few things that you could
actually do in your work
so that you take all of your mental
focus your physical energy and the
willpower that you wake up with every
single morning
and you really mono maniacally focus
those trinity of performance assets
on the few things the few projects
that when consistently iterated and
improved every day over time
will allow you to reach a place where
the world
calls you world class and if you can not
only get this idea on the 7 000
ferrari's philosophy but apply it
so it becomes a way of being you really
will own your game
and it was a poem from the bengali poet
rabindranath to gore
and allow me to share it with you it
simply said
spring has passed summer has gone
and winter is here and the song i meant
to sing remains unsung
for i have spent my days stringing
and unstringing my instrument
and my brother and i used to look at it
every morning before we go off to school
but i never really understood it and so
when i got a little older i said dad you
know that poem you had on our
refrigerator door
what was it all about and my dad looked
at me said he said robin that was a poem
written by a man whose heart was filled
with regret over a life half lived
he said robin that was a poem written by
a man who postponed
his life he always wanted to do
something special he always wanted to do
important work he always wanted to be
loving in the world
he always wanted to be creative he
always wanted to see the world
but he got busy being busy
are you being busy being busy
have you lost that connection to the
life you wanted to live when you were a
little kid
are you so busy stringing your
instrument
that the song that your life was meant
to sing
has died or is dormant within you
and my challenge to you is simply this
to do whatever it takes before you
sleep tonight to reconnect with the best
within you
that you may have lost because one of
the things i've noticed is this there
are too many amongst us
walking the planet today who are sort of
in a waking
sleep they have lost a sense of who they
truly are
and your life will never work if there's
a huge space between who you truly are
and the person you know you're meant to
be your life will never
be flooded with energy creativity
productivity and happiness
if there is a large space between your
life right now
and your unlived life and my request and
encouragement
and challenge to you is truly that you
make things happen
so that the person you are starting
tomorrow is more of who you know you
truly are
it makes me think of george bernard shaw
he was asked on his deathbed
what would you do if you could live your
life over again and he replied
after a long pause i wish i could become
the person i know i was meant to be and
i suggest to you
it's never too late for you to become
the person you've always wanted to be
but don't postpone it for next year
don't postpone it for next month
start being that person that human being
that creative force
that business builder that mother or
father
that athlete that humanitarian
that force of good that you have always
wanted to be
beginning right now legendary takes time
and you can
find yourself a gargantuan competitive
advantage
where you say i'm going to think long
term i'm going to play
the long game i understand the genius
and world class and legendary
is not a sprint it's a marathon and when
you do that you start to
raise your level of awareness and you
see your job as a craft
not just a job and you start to say i'm
not going to put anything
out into the world that is less
than steve jobs level you know steve
jobs really wasn't
an entrepreneur he really didn't care
much about the money steve jobs
really was an artist and you've probably
heard me share this before but there's
the great story about
when in the mid 1980s steve jobs said
we're going to launch the first apple
macintosh
and he said you know i want this
computer to be revolutionary
and when i interviewed steve wozniak the
co-founder and steve jobs
jobs partner at a titan summit in zurich
a little while ago i heard this
firsthand
that steve wozniak wanted to create
computers
that were just industry
that would shake up the status quo that
was his obsession
he wanted to do things no one else no
other coder could do
and he told me steve jobs was an artist
and so in the mid-1980s steve jobs got
his design team around him
and here's what he told him this is the
deliverable guys
i want this first apple macintosh to be
so beautiful
it brings tears to people's eyes but the
real deliverable is
i want the inside to be art
and the design team said well steve no
one's going to look
inside the computer no one's going to
open it up
why don't just we just focus on a
world-class user experience on the
outside and
beautiful architecture and design and he
said no this is what i want
and so when his design team went to work
and the engineering team went to work
they
literally said we've got to deliver on
steve's
obsession and when steve jobs first saw
that apple macintosh
when it was produced he started to cry
because he saw the beauty of execution
around his vision
and then when he saw the inside he was
moved deeply
because steve jobs wasn't an
entrepreneur he was much more an artist
and they looked at his design team and
he said now i want you to sign the
circuit board
and they said why and he said because
all artists
sign their work i don't know what you do
i don't know where you live one thing i
know for sure
maybe the world has not told you you are
an artist
but i encourage you see your work in
anything you produce
as poetry and your name your good
name is on what you're releasing to the
world
and rather than putting out a lot of
poetry and a lot of work
why not put out less work but work that
is legendary
society right now is defining success by
how much you
have but mahatma gandhi died with less
than 10 possessions
i mean he had a spinning wheel he had
his eye
i believe he had a watch and a few other
things
um mother teresa i was actually in
her mission in uh kolkata
in india and i went into her her bedroom
and all she had was a very spartan bed
and a desk and if you look at martin
luther king jr these people all lived
very spartan lives and very sparse lives
why
because they really didn't care about
accumulating things
they were on a monomaniacal mission
to free the population that they were
serving it's not about accumulating
things if you really want to be a
a hero of history it's about finding
some kind of a
fiery cause that fuels your passion
and that brings on your talent for the
benefit
of helping as many people as possible
and in my work i call that a cause
in my work i call that a monomaniacal
mission
and you know you don't have to be a
nelson mandela or a mother teresa
to live like this you can be a school
teacher who says you know what
here's the the higher mission i want to
dedicate the rest of my career to
and it's educating young people to
believe in themselves and to
capitalize on their on their skills
so they do great things in their lives
and they're of benefit to the world you
could be a baker
and understand that you know what your
cause could be every single person who
comes in this bakery
i will leave them better than i found
them because every day is an opportunity
to lift another human being and to to
radiate
optimism and to model possibility
you could be a taxi driver you could be
a firefighter i don't know what you do
but the difference between a victim and
a leader is a victim sees a job as a job
and a leader
sees a job as a cause and that really is
a game-changing insight if you say you
know what
i might not be leading millions but i am
leading a team at the office or i am
leading my family or i'm
i'm not leading anyone but i'm a human
being and i have the capacity to walk
out into the world
and in a world where a lot of people are
closed and a lot of people are negative
and a lot of people have walls
you can stand for possibility and you
can stand for
high energy and you can stand for hope
and you can stand for
love and that's a really profound
responsibility
and opportunity you have on your
shoulders today
lock and load you're like a navy seal
you've got the mission plan now you
execute it
here's the key the more you do difficult
things the more you'll be brilliant at
doing difficult things
you get better at what you practice
if you complain you're going to be
picasso level of complaining
if you eat bad food in terms of your
nutritional plan every day you're
literally going to hardwire
the neural circuits so that you become
roger federer level and eating bad
food if you're a victim or a toxic
person or what people call a drama mama
and that applies to men and women and if
you do it every day
for 10 000 hours thank you anders
erickson who did the research
on the 10 000 hour rule you're gonna be
f1 driver f1 champion
driver level performance
at being a drama mama if you
cut corners in your craft at work every
day you are literally
hardwiring in and
practicing and if you practice it over
10 years
10 000 hours in total you're gonna be
mozart level shakespeare level
elon musk level richard branson level
steve wozniak level shack level
kobe level
at that practicing mediocrity
you will get brilliant at what you
practice every day in a world with a lot
of people where a lot of
business people a lot of leaders a lot
of your friends
what needs to happen next year for this
to be the best year of your professional
life your personal life your financial
life
your physical life your spiritual life
your love life i don't know
most people spend a lot more time on
their summer vacations a lot more time
flipping through the social media versus
architecting
a world-class life you want to be one of
those rare air few you know my brain
tattoo
to have the results only five percent of
the population have you've got to be
willing to do
what 95 of the population are unwilling
to do
and one of those things don't be
superficial don't
live a superficial life don't have a
superficial game plan
fire proof yourself against
superficiality
and really understand this concept i've
been teaching called granularity
when i work with the nba athletes who
come into my rooms at my events
when i work with the titans the
billionaires the celebrity ceos you read
about
these people are anything but
superficial
they are granular and you can call them
obsessed you can call them
obsessive you can call them weird freaks
kooks misfits so what call them what you
want that's just a label
i'm reporting on reality these are
people who'll say let me show you my
battle plan for the next
80 days come up with 10 laws
you are going to spend or you're going
to live the remainder of
your life under that could be one of the
things i teach in my work
don't die one of the secrets to
legendary
is longevity so outlive your industry
peers
amazing what happens when you get into
such great
physical health that you just outlive
everyone around you you know it's
90 you're 90 no you have no competition
imagine how easy it will be for you to
dominate your field imagine
how good you're going to be if you're
103
still rocking your game so the point is
don't die
protect your health hack
aging eat the right supplements work out
every day get
you know run my two massage protocol
make sure you get fresh air the point is
simply this
one of your 10 life laws could simply be
don't die
one of your 10 life laws could be
give more than you take
one of your 10 life laws could be
spend an hour alone building your self
relationship you know i was reading
marcus aurelius
very early this morning the great roman
emperor
and he talked about the shortness of
life but he also talked about this
find some time every day to be amid
tranquility
so you could think see when you're in
the noise you can't
think the noise of distraction and
attraction
and diversion by technology
when you're alone and i've found it's
the best thing
first thing in the morning you can
actually think about your values
and you can actually get to know
yourself again and you can actually
breathe and you can actually contemplate
what am i going to do today how am i
going to live
how can i make today on earth a valuable
day
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action you have a 91 chance of
following through
that's what we do here believe nation we
get motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances even further of following
through
so what was your biggest takeaway from
this video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you most leaders most business people
most entrepreneurs most human beings
have never
learned to be masterful communicators
and the very nature of influence and
impact which is the leader's job is
communication
i mean in school were you given a
communication course
very few people have been taught that in
your
personal relationships have you read
books on communication
well that leads to i mean in in an
intimate relationship
or even just with a friend it's the
little miscommunications that over time
stack into loss in your intimate
relationships
it's the little conversations
that you could have had in five minutes
if you had the tools to communicate and
the awareness to speak
so literally you could release the anger
and build understanding
and speak out your needs and feel the
need to be heard
all those little things if you had
learned how to do that over
and done it in five minutes with your
intimate partner
you might not have lost the relationship
and in your professional life
learning to communicate inspires your
teammates you know if you look at the
great leaders of humanity the nelson
mandela's the mother
teresa the martin luther king jr the
john f
kennedys if you look at the great
business builders steve jobs
great example right he would be on the
stage
at the product launch and then that
favorite line one more thing
and that's when he would reveal the
latest piece of technology
that would create industry dominance
when steve jobs
was at apple well he was a masterful
communicator and
bud tribble over at apple called it his
reality distortion field
steve jobs was a master salesman he knew
exactly what to say
to get people to believe in the
impossible
to allow their i can't to be less
valuable
than their i can't if you want an
eight-hour video of the best of tony
robbins motivation
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there let me tell you
this we said to have an extraordinary
life you got to have an extraordinary
psychology right
extraordinary psychology means you got
to live in an extraordinary state